Claudio pouvait 2022 a été votre année
vous avez fait la couverture du hall
Québec
d'abord je recommence 2023 démarre en
lion parce que tu es capitaine au sein
de la compétition musicale Zénith
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour toi ce
grand défilé en direct les jeudi soir
quand même et ben c'est ma première
expérience de direct c'est la première
fois aussi que je me retrouve un peu
derrière un peu plus en mode animation
donc ça va être un beau défi pour moi
d'user de mon de ma répartie en direct
on va être 100 ici dans la pièce avec
des roues l'équipe technique tout le
monde est en vallée tout le monde est
vraiment excité
ta carrière a commencé avec une autre
compétition musicale en 2011 mix Mania 2
ouais
vraiment j'avais 15-16 ans à l'époque
envie dans le domaine artistique avec
Mixmania ça c'était extrêmement je sais
pas si je sais pas je sais à quel point
c'était
complètement déstabilisant et
extrême comme expérience je pense pas
que j'étais utile pour vivre ça moi en
sortant de cette émission là je pouvais
pas me déplacer sans me faire arrêter
sans je me souviens les premières fois
que je suis allée à la ronde je peux pas
faire de ma neige c'était super intense
c'était trop moche c'était vraiment
intense puis reste que ça m'a donné une
force de caractère et ça j'ai beaucoup
appris de ça
il y a quelques mois tu as lancé en
premier album de Paradise club avec
l'excellente douchebag mais la chanson
qui a vraiment cartonné c'est sur le net
avec la petite pause de batterie la base
[Musique]
pour toi c'est quoi une bonne chanson
pour moi une bonne chanson c'est bon je
suis adepte du pop ce qui est très drôle
parce que quand j'étais jeune je voulais
pas faire de pop pour moi la pop était
synonyme de bonbons j'étais très jeune
aussi j'avais pas d'expérience donc
j'avais bien peur de tomber dans un
espèce de frame finalement il y a rien
de meilleur que de la pop après ça moi
j'aime explorer au travers de la pop
c'est pour ça que je dis que je fais de
la pop alternative j'explore j'aime
travailler les sons et tout mais pour
moi une bonne chanson il va avoir un
hook accrocheur ça c'est super important
le thème de la chanson doit être clair
faut en termes d'écriture faut que tu
puisses aller chercher les
mains la clé dans la chanson qui fait en
sorte que les gens peuvent se
reconnaître comprendre
ta génération la génération Z c'est
celle des réseaux sociaux TikTok
Instagram pas Facebook je le sais c'est
pour les
mais pour votre carrière c'est essentiel
ça c'est c'est une bonne question parce
que je pense que
je suis pas contre les réseaux sociaux
mais par contre je pense qu'on devrait
être
on devrait avoir des ressources pour
nous aider à utiliser les réseaux
sociaux de façon intelligente puis de
parce que je pense vraiment que il y a
un réel gouffre dans les réseaux sociaux
je pense que on en est tous victimes moi
des fois je vais je vais me retrouver
mon dos ça fait 45 minutes que je suis
en train
un robot le chat puis moi ça fait
beaucoup ma créativité si je commence ma
journée sur mon téléphone cellulaire mes
idées vont pas être bonnes restantes de
la journée
je pense que il faudrait avoir des
ressources pour être capable de faire
une utilisation intelligente pour que
qu'on puisse l'utiliser de à ce que on
s'inspire réellement je pense que à
l'école on devrait avoir des cours pour
bien l'utiliser
[Musique]
du cinéma
important dans ta carrière tout a
commencé et tu as fait du cinéma
Charlotte et puis le nouveau film qui
sort le respect Honor camarades
pour toi aussi
le jeu a longtemps été
l'opposé d'une zone de confort très
déstabilisant pour moi parce que ça
m'est arrivé dans ma vie j'avais pas
jamais pris de cours puis
des années j'apprends de plus en plus à
prendre ma place et à aller à m'amuser
dans le jeu et à ne pas me mettre de
pression donc à ce statut je dirais que
oui c'est un plaisir coupable merci pour
cette belle rencontre merci
[Musique]